[Music]
day 62 intentions are running sky-high
on the set of love and thunder because
this mood is an all-time low so i'm
about to go and help pick up the spirits
with my bubbly energetic personality
[Music]
this is ten years for me
i'd have loved every time i played the
character this new film transitions us
from end game into a rebirth for doesn't
know what his place is in the universe
that's represented in his wardrobe as
well
i was really excited to come back as the
mighty thor
to have both of us in the same cape
um that was amazing and incredible
especially with tyka at the helm tucker
he's like a big kid he's like sort of a
genius child
i wasn't afraid to be flamboyant and a
bit camp
three two one
giant goats look at those they are
wonderful yes they are they also scream
quite a lot it's hugely imaginative and
fun like such an enormous scale
it's a crazy space adventure with a new
villain he's pretty monstrous
oh god she won't die
we really raised the bar with ragnarok
love and thunder is even more unique and
different so it's pretty exciting
[Music]
[Music]
you